[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm rhett
and i'm link this week at the round
table of dim lighting
we're going to talk about some of your
most
embarrassing holiday memories because we
thought you know what
the holidays are strange this year and
strained
i mean a lot of plans have been altered
or canceled all together i mean as we've
discussed
neither one of us are going home for the
holidays because of
because of the pandemic and and all the
unknowns and
um so we're you know we're sitting here
in this
in this weird holiday experience
different from any we've ever had
and i just thought it would be it would
be fun to
to talk about embarrassing things that
have happened over the holidays so then
we could at least say
if you're not going home if you're not
seeing your loved ones you could at
least be like well
at least the chances of something that
embarrassing happening have gone down
drastically well i mean
i don't know i don't i can embarrass
myself
in front of my own immediate family
i guess it is harder to do though
especially depending on what kind of
family you you go home to like
if you're if you are like a new spouse
which we've got a couple of those
situations
like going home to for christmas
with your new spouse
for the first time or you're just like a
new
boyfriend girlfriend kind of thing like
i think that's where there's the most
potential for embarrassment because
you're entering into an unknown
situation you don't know how they're
going to treat you doing what kind of
things they're going to say
i mean what kind of environment are you
walking into are you going are you going
to say the wrong thing
are you going to look at somebody the
wrong way you gotta not understand
uncle barry uncle barry you know
you're not to worry about that this year
yeah that's been that's so long ago for
us
i can i can i can barely remember
just getting in like before they were my
in-laws like
going going going in on christmas with
them but
but it was especially situated youtube
i had a whole lot of interaction with my
wife's family
even before we started dating really
because that's how that's how i got to
know jesse was by knowing her family
first so it was a little bit less of a
and definitely by the time we were
married it was like pressurized yeah we
live
we live actually we lived above their
garage
that's right in that little one bedroom
with a slanting uh the slanting roof
that i had i had a duck
just to walk around up there well i mean
we we we grew up around our families
like whenever
like our you know christie started being
introduced to my family it was like once
that was more of a dating thing than a
holiday thing because we all lived in
relatively the same area but for other
people yeah it's like
introducing someone to your significant
other for the first time happens a lot
around the holidays
and you were we also weren't i mean
as different as your family might be
from your wife's family or my
family might be from my wife's family
we're still all a bunch of people from
from north carolina like it's not like
you're going you're going to a whole
different culture or something like that
so it was like i kind of know what i'm
getting myself into here right
um well before we get into those stories
though i have an embarrassing story
um that i already told you but now i'm
gonna tell everybody
everybody needs to hear this um it's not
embarrassing for me
it's not really a holiday story either
but i felt a little
i it was i felt a little embarrassed uh
when you
when you share the full extent of it
with me okay well
but let him have it um yesterday
as a matter of fact this happened
we're recording this on a monday and
yesterday
uh i took the boys my two sons lock and
shepard on a sunday drive now you've
you've been doing some family driving
and you've talked about that during the
pandemic very early on in quarantine it
was like you know what
we're just going to drive around we're
not we're going to see what's happening
or not happening but we're not going to
get out of the car we're going to see in
the safety of a car
that kind of trickled off after a while
and i was just like i'm going to take
the boys
kind of get them out and you know there
was like talk of going trick-or-treating
a little foreshadowing for you uh
we were talking about maybe like going
to the beach or going surfing but we're
like what if we just drove
and we stopped at a bunch of places and
you know we've got one of the most
famous drives that you can do in the
entire world
is the pch and it's right here we can
just get on it the pacific coast highway
is what that stands for so this is the
highway that goes right up the coast
so we the one i had never eaten
at this place called neptune's net which
is the place
i haven't either now it's it's pretty
far north
it's a county line beach so all the way
at the county line between
oh above malibu yeah i mean like if
you're
oh you're on the way out there well that
was the whole idea we were gonna drive
all the way to oxnard
see what see what oxnard's all about the
you know some kind of a weird name
and uh i've always kind of been
interested in like what's going over
here
what's what's happening in oxnard and
ventura uh-huh
but we never make it out that way and
i i had uh had had intentions of eating
at neptune's net
at for some time but of course
you know we coveted and everything
wasn't making my way down there
but i go online and there's like a
drive-through situation
and let me tell you not that neptune's
net needs any more business because it
was
it was very busy but they have it
figured out
what do you mean is it is it like a
fried seafood place i think that they
are probably most known for their fried
seafood but they also have
um grilled seafood okay fish tacos
hamburgers lots of things but they got
the drive-through coved thing figured
out
very well they have some outdoor seating
which we didn't do we were just like
we're gonna do the drive-through thing
and maybe like eat in the car
you know safety first uh-huh i'm always
on the fence about fish and chips
i i don't want to talk about fish and
chips i want to talk about what happened
i know but i got to say that
i got to say this man they they got
they if you are on the fence about
fishing ships like i was
this will completely redeem it so um
that was our first stop driving all the
way up malibu
and we stopped at neptune's net go
through the drive-through
get our food eat it in the car and then
we're like all right let's take a little
stroll down to the beach let's go down
to the beach
and okay i'm promising this with letting
you know
i'm not a braggy daddy but i own a tesla
that is the car that i drive if you
remember the society you've seen me
drive it in some of the carpool vlogs
but i have to say that by way of setting
the context for
why what happened happened
so tesla has this thing called sentry
mode
which is there's cameras on the car
and is you can have it set so that when
you leave the car
and it knows you left the car because
your phone is the key to the car right
and so when you get away you walk away
from the car the car locks
and it automatically goes into sentry
mode which is it is recording
everything that is happening around your
car so if somebody comes up and
all the cameras that are used to to help
it navigate and know oh there's you're
passing a pedestrian
or another car is in your blind spot or
like when you drive your car
it shows trash cans on the side of the
road and i actually don't think that
that's using i think it's using the
cameras and maybe like some sort of
lidar or something
okay but the camera is everywhere for
like backing up and maneuvering
so there's but they're constantly
recording there's a camera in the front
camera in the back and then two cameras
on the sides
um and so what it'll do if somebody
comes up to the car
it actually if you get close to the car
when it's in sentry mode
if you happen to look inside the car and
you see this big screen it'll say
sentry mode you are being recorded or
something like that like it lets you
know so people who are like trying to
break in oh crap i'm being recorded and
you have to hook a hard drive
up to your to your car like a little usb
hard drive is like in the console and so
it did
so then when you come back to the car it
says 14th century mode
events recorded and then you go and you
watch them if you
so please so
we're walking on the beach and i get a
an alert on my phone sentry
sentry recording initiated or something
like that oh
and then it was like car alarm
in initiated which has never happened
you know and the whole time i've owned
the car could you stop it
or what did you do did you run back to
the car no
because i was like this is probably just
um
you can't like look into you can't it's
not like a nest cam where you can like
look and see what the car is recording
from your phone i was just like this is
probably one of those there's so many
motorcycles
on the pch and lots of loud motorcycles
and i was like this is probably just a
loud motorcycle going by and setting the
alarm off
because i'd seen so many so i didn't
we kept walking around and then we go
back to the car and uh
you can go you can bring up the files
and there's a little red dot
on the like the you know you can scroll
to the red dot to see what the event was
yeah
and so we just like okay there's like 15
events recorded i'm like
let's see what set the car the car alarm
off and we were kind of doing it just
to have fun you know showing the boys
like how this works
and uh so we kind of go through most of
it is just people walking past the car
is is what set the set the little red
dot off
and then oh here's where the car alarm
went off oh yes it was a giant harley
that went by like
wouldn't just set it off you know wow
but then there's this other event
and we scroll to it and uh now just give
me an idea
the camera on it's like the camera is in
the
rearview mirror and it's fit and it's
it's
showing you like the length of the car
like like hey i wouldn't call it
on the car i would call it a blind spot
mirror like yeah yeah it's
it's shooting behind like past the car
where a car would be in your box so if
someone comes and stands next to you
to your car you see their entire body
but the camera is
really kind of focused right on their
midsection which is important
yeah or like where where yeah where you
would aim
a camera if someone were in a car
driving the middle of the body
car level now in addition to people on
motorcycles there's lots of people on
bicycles
and we see oh there's a older man
um you know who's been riding a bicycle
he's got the full
like bike gear on in the helmet
and he walks right up to our car
looks over his shoulder and then whips
it out
and by it i mean his penis
i don't know why he gotta say it like
that he's weiner man
says weiner is weiner
and proceeds to urinate
[Laughter]
and it's one of those things that once
you start seeing it you can't it's not
like i mean we
we just me and the boys just start
laughing
hysterically well let me tell you
uh rhett played this video for me
[Laughter]
uh i wouldn't say that i was begging to
see it but
but i didn't i didn't tell you what you
were about to see i you know you didn't
you didn't
you didn't describe like the the
composite of the shot
to the point where you've just described
it to everyone listening now
and i would i mean just picture
if you needed to pee and there was a
webcam
and like like at like groin level
and you just walked you walked up to it
and peed right next to it like
like i mean face like hips squared up
to the camera right just like it wasn't
like oh i can see this
i can tell this guy's peeing and he's
peeing like away from me or
uh he was a peeing away from everything
else except the camera he was peeing
basically right towards the camera right
but he was peeing away from like
the road and the people i mean he was
like he was but he was parallel with the
road i guess he didn't turn away
which is it's almost like he knew how
tesla's work but i don't think
i don't think that he does i don't think
he did but you should know he had no
he had no so no p fright
yeah it was just it it landed like there
it was and then here it comes
and i completely understand when you're
biking down the pch you got to find the
spot right yeah and this is what you're
going to do you're going to go inside
just like people who get finished
surfing and they just pee on the side of
the road it happens often
i mean i don't have anything against the
guy for doing it but
i'm just saying i just don't know why we
sat there and watched
it's like once you know what's happening
i don't you know
we we didn't just stop while we watched
the whole
event well it didn't last that long it
was a i mean it was pretty short
it must stop quite a bit
seven seconds it was crazy man no it's
just like
my boys got the biggest kick out of it
because you know first of all
they kept just talking about how great
of a day they were having they were like
we got to do this more often oh that's
good
but then when they would talk about what
they would remember they'd be like well
the main thing we're going to remember
is that
is that old man peeing on the camera he
didn't
the p didn't go on no no no but
it couldn't have been it couldn't have
been more
fortuitously framed well here's the
thing i think this serves as a warning
right
now of course i'm not you know i'm not
gonna i mean
that footage lives on my hard drive
which i guess i will delete it
um but for the video version we're
cutting to it
right yeah right no we're not we are
obviously not sharing that uh although
he would i mean he did
it was a public urination situation
that's illegal you're technically not
supposed to do that
um and of course i didn't film him
there was no permission involved it was
just you do this next to my car my car
records things just i don't know what
the
legalities of that are i i you know i
would get i would give him high marks
for his um
his post shaking regimen like he had a
very rigorous
he ended with a very rigorous shake well
he's about to get back on a bike
i mean i i i was afraid it was going to
fall off um
for a second there but very rigorous
just let this be a warning the shaking
if you've got to urinate in public i
mean first of all
maybe find a different way what's the
frame rate of your camera can we can we
slow that down
i'm not i'm not watching it again okay
yes you are
no i'm not come on man uh
do not do it next to a tesla i mean i'm
more i'm sure more cars have this
feature but just
just you know tesla's they all got this
feature
now whether or not somebody's got it
turned on or not
i mean i think why not turn it on let's
not use the phrase turned off
just don't do it if you're going to pee
next to a tesla
face away from the tesla don't like get
parallel and like pee towards the mirror
because there is a camera
in there right there right there yeah
right there waist level
oh my goodness yeah it was it's gonna be
hard to forget that thank you
i mean thank you for sharing
i mean i think we probably just saved
some people a lot of heartache
you know people are like hey i gotta pee
hold on don't get go pee next to an
old car you know what i'm saying just
pee next to an old car the older the car
the safer it is to pee next to it
oh man yeah that's embarrassing
i was embarrassed to be watching that
but it's over
yeah it's over you know what i didn't do
anything wrong no one did anything wrong
well he didn't do something but i mean
yeah okay
all right so we're going to get into
your embarrassing stories we're going to
react to those
see see what's shaking on your front oh
god
i didn't mean it like that really
shaking on your front
i kind of meant it that way but i was
like what's shaking on the home front
what shaking on your front is not even
the same no it's not
i was trying to make it work uh but
first
it didn't work we are going to let you
know that over at mythical.com
our website that has a store we sell
a mask the mythical neon
mask it's really a black mask with neon
writing yeah we call it the neon mask
it's not a neon mask it's a neon
black mask with neon text doesn't it
it's great
it's um it's got a great fit to it
you know you got to get the right right
ones and it's the only good one it's got
the filters that you can put inside of
it
too like the carbon or whatever it is
you know
something or whatever else it is that
you would want from mythical.com rep
your boys
my aunt tc she texted me and she was
like
i love how your your shirts feel
that you sell on your website um
i i'd i'd like to get a few more of
those and i was like okay just tell me
tell me your size and i i shipped it or
some and she got them
this morning she sent me a she order she
sent me a voicemail well she didn't
order specific ones i just told
i told jenna to pick out something that
she thought would be ant worthy
okay and then she just sent them so i
don't even know what she got
specifically
uh because it's not shipped from here
you know [ __ ] from the warehouse
she said she said that she she she went
through
sam's club and i'm sure she was masked
up and safe
but some employee there said i love your
shirt
and she was like yep yeah well that's my
nephew and she was like which one
and she was like link she was like well
i watch
i watch everything they do that was the
conversation everybody had an aunt vicky
sighting
not aunt vicky aunt tc aunt tc yeah aunt
tc
okay uh story makes a little more sense
all of a sudden
why because aunt vicky wouldn't go to
sam's no i just don't
vicki's not asking for merch right tc's
asking yeah right that's
that's the thing and she's she she she
likes the feel of it but she was also
wanting to rep
her nephew repping your boys you know it
leads to conversations
you connect with other mythical beasts
out there in the wild
that's what it's all about that and
that's making a little bit of scratch
yeah everybody wins mythical.com
let's start with a story yes holly at
holly some the number one someone
someone holly someone i introduced my
boyfriend
james to my family by the wrong name
in my defense i just told my told him my
cousin's name is
jackson so that was fresh in my brain at
least they start with the same two
letters
yeah so yeah we're in this place where
you're bringing your significant other
home they're meeting family members for
the first time if you
if you if you're if you can't get their
name right that is that is
quite embarrassing well the question is
how long did this go on was this a
uh i would like you guys to meet um
jackson i mean
silly me james or was it i would like
you to meet
jackson and then just letting it sit for
a while and then he has to be like um
yeah it's actually it's james because
that that that's more embarrassing if he
had to clarify
and that information is not available we
do not have that information it's not
available i choose to believe it was
it was really the latter yeah yeah that
like she never she didn't
she forgot his name forever now i have
name fright it's the type of thing that
like once you start to believe that
you're gonna get somebody's name wrong
then you will start to get people's
names wrong there's like some
psychological downward spiral that i
just i thought that naming it
and being more honest about it and
public with it would help
but you couldn't remember the name to
name it but it doesn't it
it's not helping that much like you know
it's
occasionally over the course of our
the job that we do we have to say
people's names
like be it a guest on our show or if
we're giving a shout out to somebody or
something or other or just referring to
somebody
and if you know it's if if
pronunciations are
are difficult then that that plays into
my name for it too
it's like okay this is how you say this
person's name
you got to get it right it's like the
more i concentrate on getting it right
the more i will get it wrong
and i just know it's going to happen
it's like it's self-sabotage you
remember
we're not going to name any names but
that happened to me
that happened to me on on an episode of
gmm
i'm not going to tell you when it was oh
yeah a guest we had a guest
and uh this person's last name wasn't
necessarily straightforward you know it
seems like there was a couple of ways
you could go with it
and of course we we make sure that we
know how to pronounce everybody's names
so someone came and told me this is how
you say
their name and so i was like really
concentrating on like okay this is how
you say it this is how you say it this
is how you say it
and then we were doing our little opener
where we introduced the person
and not only did i say the name
wrong which i said it the way that i was
told to say it in my defense
but it was wrong and then i also so you
did say what you practiced
i said what i practiced but then i also
said
the name of
the thing that they were promoting wrong
because it was wrong that information
was also wrong
so and then so this wasn't my fault but
i kind of and then she we were in the
middle of the show
immediately well we had to cut to go
into title
and so this person was like by the way
it's so and so
and it's the song so i think it's so and
so
you know i was like oh man and this
person was gracious
at the time but it's one of those things
you just immediately are like
oh man now that's the only thing i can
think about is the fact that i got those
two things wrong
yeah and i i i it's so
i i like saying people's names right
because it makes them feel good
but then when you say it wrong it's like
you know you're just another person who
said their name wrong it's like you
don't want to be that person
well does this extend you know people
you're dating
you should probably get their names
right but for you does it extend
to like
family not family members but okay
somebody has a new baby in your in in
your family like
you got a new nephew or a new niece or
something like that oh yeah i mean
does name fright extend into those
situations
uh i can't think of can't think of your
nieces
uh it depends there's a little bit of
that yeah yeah i don't know if that's
happened with me yet
but if you're dating somebody you just
gotta you gotta you gotta get it
straight
let's ask another one clumsy christmas
that's like the subtitle that i put on
that one from
hikate is that how you would say that
i mean h tyson yeah
12. getting so drunk at my brother's
ugly christmas sweater party i fell
down the stairs inside the house
in front of no less than 25 people and
broke
my coccyx oh the tailbone spent the next
few
months having to sit on a special pillow
at work
and people thought i had hemorrhoids and
not a broken ass
i mean so hemorrhoids are more
embarrassing than
getting drunk and busting your ass i
mean well it's more drawn
out come on it's more drawn out if you
if you people think you have hemorrhoids
i mean even if no one's watching like
falling on your butt like
breaking your coccyx like the end of
your spine
that it hurts so bad it's what you know
did you
did you actually break the coccyx when
you broke your pelvis no
you just bruised it or was it not or was
it not i mean
i hit it's just one of the rings busted
then you you can either hit the rings at
the bottom of your pelvis or you can i
guess you can hit the coccyx
there was some someone else we know
maybe somebody who worked here or was it
a family member that like
broke their coccyx but when you when you
land on that thing
it's just like you're just oh
it's that type of pain that there's
there's nothing you can do it's just it
your body freezes
and you're just like i'm in so much pain
i can't
i can't do anything this is gonna last
forever
and every millisecond is like an
eternity
and it's it's very it's very particular
to this
bus in your butt issue but in the
context there's a few things that hurt
in that way
but in the context of first of all being
drunk helps with the pain
but uh it might actually help with the
embarrassment but think about how like
you would immediately try to like walk
that off
depending on the kind of person you are
if you burn people get hurt
and gather a crowd and some people get
hurt and say i'm okay i'm okay i'm
actually dying
but yeah i'm okay it's like a dog going
somewhere
going underneath the house to die right
the thing that this brings to mind for
me though
is the threshold
of a size of a party in which you can
comfortably get
to you can drink too much right so it's
so
i don't i mean i don't i don't enjoy
drinking
that much and i and i don't enjoy
getting i mean
a few drinks and i'm like okay i feel
good but
a few more drinks i what whatever
happens after that i'm going to feel so
bad that
i just prevent myself from going there
yeah me too i think there's also like a
i've had a i've had like a couple of i
had too much to drink and that
it wasn't that i got like embarrassingly
drunk
but i just sick i it's like i skipped
like party mode and all i remember
and it because it wasn't that fulfilling
and i went straight to this i feel like
crap mode like worst headache ever
hangover even even the same night not
even the next morning
yeah like having a severe reaction you
know i like to stay hydrated
we know so if yeah i i've
i i don't like drinking too much because
it's it it's just simply not worth it
right but so there's and i haven't
brought busted my coffee well but okay
so there's so there's a physical
there's the physical effects that kind
of keep me but
uh let's just say that those didn't
exist right
let's just say that there was no
hangover that you had to worry about
there's there's still the thing this is
what i'm trying to get at is
there are a size of a group and also a
familiarity of a group that it's kind of
like okay i'm going to get drunk
and it doesn't matter because i'm with
my family i'm with my really close
friends there's nobody who's i can't
embarrass
myself but okay but there are certain
settings
and i think a a party with 25 people
we're definitely
we're in a place where there's so many
people there
uh that might not even know you or let's
just say
a work a work holiday party which is the
classic thing for people to
get smashed at a work holiday party
right
um and you just got you just got to
think about it a little bit and you got
to think about it
early in the night right you got to
think about it early in the night
i mean we're not having a we're not
having a uh for obvious reasons we're
not having a party this year
uh yes we are well we're not having a
virtual party
and we are making drinks i mean people
can make their own drink
according to some sort of holiday recipe
that somebody's got to come up with that
by the way
and instead of spending money on a venue
we spent money on uh
mythical a mythical outfit for everyone
everybody's going to put their mythical
outfit on
yeah and make drinks um
but no but especially if you like cozy
out if you if you
if you get a good bartender they're
going to make those drinks strong and
you can get like two drinks in and you
can be like
uh oh okay another drink
and i may start regretting things you
really gotta have your you gotta have
your radar on
well you know for that kind of thing and
we haven't been in that environment that
much i mean the environment that we grew
up in was like
anti-drinking you know and it was yeah
and our families it wasn't like
we didn't have any relatives who
embarrassed themselves but getting drunk
and and yeah and our family
get-togethers
my family get-togethers there wasn't
alcohol involved it's like i think about
that
robert earl keane christmas song the
opening line
mom got drunk and dad got drunk at our
christmas party
you know that song yeah yeah that is a
that is a christmas in the
family what is it it's very funny
but it's um yeah it's just
culturally like different families they
have different
they have different approaches to like
getting inebriated
right some people and some some people
are like i'm you know if i'm drinking
and i'm not leaving
i'm getting drunk and i don't care who's
here that's just some people's mentality
and and you get to get i mean it seems
very foreign to think getting together
with family members
and just just three sheets to the wind
you know it's i mean there's but i feel
like that's the acceptable place to do
it
it is it does seem safer to like if
everybody evening everyone everybody
everybody knows you everybody loves you
you can still embarrass yourself you can
still marry
yeah but it depends on who you are you
know it depends on what you do when you
get drunk some people get mad
well some people get mad and want to
start a fight yeah let's not go there
i i actually think we're going there a
little bit later yeah but
so it's like i mean hikate going to her
brother's
ugly christmas sweater party and just
busting her ass
i mean you can get hurt i mean i mean
that's that that is embarrassing
yeah it could have been a lot worse
though yeah so i guess i guess it broke
your neck
what i'm saying is uh this is something
that can be avoided this year in most
places because you're probably not gonna
have a holiday party don't you
i remember that
there were some parents when we were in
high school
and maybe two sets of prayers like if
you're gonna drink
just come i would rather for you to come
over here and do it
at our house and of course
you know we were in full baptist mode
around this time i think well maybe we
had gone non-denominational
but still but we were very much but it
was from a baptist background which was
like
don't touch it if you're gonna drink you
gotta act like you don't you gotta hide
it
well and we thought and i don't even
know how what i would but we
judged those families they were like oh
my gosh why would a
why would a parent allow their
underage drinking in their home and it
was like it was just a
you know i i don't know i mean it's i
don't i haven't even thought about this
as it pertains to us as parents but
i do think that there it's it's like
there's also there's a legal
there's a legal issue here you know when
you're the uh when you are the adult
who is providing the place for underage
kids and then some underage kid is gonna
bust their coccyx and then they're under
your care
technically that that could be a problem
so i do think there is something to like
going
into like a field somewhere and popping
one open
versus i'm just so surprised and all the
times that we went out
camping across the river like i don't
recall ever
i mean we made we made ours you made
your own wine and
we took it out there and drank it but it
just felt not very much justified
yeah it felt different it was more like
a culmination to a
a farming process it wasn't like a
clandestine let's get
drunk i mean there was we didn't get
anything off of that
but we didn't we didn't like take any
mad dog or any that stuff out but we did
take well we
took like chewing tobacco out there you
know which is
which felt different but it was but it
was technically illegal i mean
it was technically illegal if i i think
we were
we were contributing to the local
economy yeah right you know
the convenience store clerk that the
farmers
on the outskirts of town it was easier
to justify
and you're not gonna the the the danger
in
in
too much chewing tobacco at least you
know in the short term
it's pretty low uh here's what i'll say
just moving back to drinking with your
kids okay let's talk more about that can
we talk about drinking with our kids
um no i i mean i anticipate a day
when the kids are older certainly of
drinking age
and and much older it's like even in
grand
grandkids territory they're bringing the
grandkids over we're getting together
for the holidays it's like
we should yeah we should be able to
enjoy a bottle of wine together
when your kids are adults and have kids
of course
but it's right but it's not the type of
thing that like i thought you talked
about drinking with the grandkids
and i was like okay well let's talk
about that but when
i was joking but when we go when we
would go home for the holidays in
previous years
i mean it was
drinking would be something that would
like like if my dad was out there
grilling for the
for like a meal we might share a beer
you know yeah when i turned 21 and like
me and my dad
i think i there was like a this
formative
camping trip that me and my dad went on
he had a camper and like we drank beer
together
for the first time it's like a rite of
passage kind of thing
but it culturally because of the whole
the baptist thing
drinking was has never been and still is
not really a part of any of our family
get-togethers
it's just a um it's just not something
that
that happens given that situation so it
actually feels
like what i said when you're like of
course you can share a bottle of wine
with your family it's like but that
wasn't
the experience that i had when i would
visit family
you know i mean that i mean that kind of
big you know
you know my parents my a little bit
a little bit of wine i mean if you
consider a white zinfandel wine
uh they might have like a sutter home a
little little
single bottle of sutter home you know
growing up in in in being
being you know baptist or
non-denominational like they
you know and i'll enjoy a glass of wine
with
a dinner every once in a while kind of
thing and so
even as an adult uh we
i would still do that but it's but again
it's there's not really
nobody on either side of our family is
getting
blitzed it is really into like i'm gonna
make a bunch of cocktails for everybody
it's like
so there's just that right that that
just doesn't exist but i mean
there's fun to be had with an with a
nice cocktail or three
depending on how you're spacing it and
who's around i mean
if you can't have fun like that with
your family
then who you going to have it with
you're going to have it at somebody at
your brother's house and you're going to
break your coccyx
yeah you just got to know your
environment i just don't want my
my kids to grow up and then them to be
totally comfortable
drinking responsibly and then they come
home and visit me and they feel like
they gotta tiptoe around
that's a strange thing that is not going
to happen but that
did it was something that happened with
my family
i get that yeah i don't i don't think oh
we're drinking a beer but it's out here
by the grill i'm not going to drink one
in any danger of that
table being the case in your family
moving forward yeah
right but it is a it's an interesting
dynamic still going back home for
christmas like if we went back next year
it's like
i bet we would have had a little bit
more fun
with a little bit of you know social
lubrication well some people just need
that just to get through
being with being with their families
yeah let's not i mean let's not talk
about it as a coping mechanism but
i'm just saying but we could for some
people like me
listen i i get it okay here we go
give me another embarrassing story don't
hold back this one is from uh
lena she got the name chia lincoln i'm
lit
right now by the way i'm just joking
on water uh chi lincoln on twitter wow
okay
we always go for a christmas eve meal at
my local restaurant
it's like a buffet self-serve thing for
my village good luck with that
so one year when i was 13 i was walking
back to my family's table
and tripped on a cable running across
the floor to power the christmas tree
lights and fell over
moving to the second tweet this is a
long story smashing my plate
and food went everywhere they cut the
christmas music to see what was going on
was there a record scratch sound effect
i was so embarrassed
i just laid motionless pretending i'd
passed out
because that seemed like the least
embarrassing thing to do
my parents still teased me about it
every christmas lena played possum
they cut the music and they're looking
around to see what happened to the
lights
and she's laying face down and you're
dirty wow just
just still this is
remarkable at a certain point you gotta
get up
yeah but slowly as if you passed out i
mean why does that make it better it
just makes people more concerned yeah
but
it does make it significantly less
embarrassing
i mean i gotta say oh you're with this
hold on play in possum situation
tripping like okay do you do you want
people
to like up to like be mocking you with
applause like they do at restaurants
when things fall
or do you want people to be coming up
and being like oh my goodness are you
okay
we thought you would die no let me just
let me just say
i would never do this because i am the
king
of trying to play things off even if
they can't be played off
so i would try to act like it was no big
deal and maybe try to like
say something but this is a i like this
plan
just face down quiet until someone comes
up and rolls you over
i mean just just the
the complex nature of the the emotion of
embarrassment
can we just have an aside about that for
a second you know it's
you have to know so so much about how
your personality and your culture and
your situation is constructed
so that you you've done something to
screw it up and you feel intense
shame is that what it is it's just like
yeah
i have done something that any you know
most of the time you feel embarrassed
for things that it could have been
anybody you know everybody's tripped and
fallen
and and like stopped and stopped the
lights
or you know there's been ramifications
but
when it happens to you it's as if you're
the only person that's ever happened to
and it's usually something yeah and it's
usually something you like you said you
didn't intend to do
it's not the spirit you didn't you
didn't intend it to go this way
i think what you're getting at is it
would be very difficult to make a robot
embarrassed
like think of the code that would have
to go
into an ai yeah
in order to program embarrassment and do
we want
embarrassment to be a part of the code i
mean i think you do right
it's hard to touch it's hard to trust
someone who can't be embarrassed
but it certainly is admirable when
somebody like
just owns something that normally would
be embarrassing
like you stand at me like i tripped
i also didn't think we needed lights
this year or
you know it's saying something to play
it off for sure but i've never thought
about it this way but don't you find
wouldn't you find it difficult to trust
someone who couldn't be embarrassed
someone who was literally shameless um
wouldn't that be i mean either they were
so well adjusted
and so shameless implies like doing
things on purpose that most people would
be embarrassed to do
didn't have the ability to have shame or
just didn't have the ability to be
embarrassed
regardless of what they said and what
they did i mean there are people like
that
my my aunt faye
she was like that i think she's passed
away i passed away i'm embarrassed to
say that
like we've lost so many people on that
side of the family in rapid succession
that like i think she was one of them
but we weren't that close
every time she said something to me it
was just like brutally honest because
she had no
she had no filter she had no filter of
if she was embarrassing anybody or
embarrassing herself
and it was i i approached her with
trepidation
right every year at the family reunion
or at the holidays at the new year's eve
thing it'd be like
she was she was the first person to just
come up to me to my face and be like
you dye your hair
she was like good lord why do you
you dye your hair don't you is that why
you stopped because of aunt faye
it was certainly a factor it's like man
she's exposing my
my fakeness why am i doing this this is
the last straw
you just know you just did it too hard i
did do it too hard yeah
i it crept up on me mm-hmm you got too
used to it
and it's not the type of person that i
wanted to be but i didn't want to
and i also it doesn't feel good to be
embarrassed by somebody
or to be afraid that somebody's going to
expose you yeah she and because she had
the inability to be embarrassed she
embarrassed you
she made it happen in you oh yeah this
reminds me of
jessie my wife had an aunt who passed
away
years ago her grandmother's sister
and um she are you talking about the
brain woman
yeah she she actually had back in the
day
when lobotomies were a thing now again
crazy in actual medical history
the lobotomy was any sort of surgery on
the brain to address a condition right
i don't remember all the things that she
was struggling with but it was very
significant right
and it was affecting her life so they
did the experimental surgery that they
did in like the 50s
where they would literally sever the
connection between the left and the
right brain this is something that's
been done
and it's fascinating to study the people
who've had their the two lobes separated
because they can literally be two
different people and so it's fascinating
to read the literature on this
but whatever they did when they went in
there they also
got rid of any impulse to be
embarrassed or self-conscious about
anything
and so and this happened when she was a
teenager so she lived her entire life
very productive life married with kids
uh she was a loose cannon she was so
direct
like she was the kind of person that you
go
and see her and you knock on her door
and she'd open the door and she'd look
and she'd be like well you've gained
weight
you know but and and some people do that
as a jab and she was just doing it
because she was like well you probably
have gained weight and she's just
she's going to just first thing that
came across it came through her brain
outer mouth but i mean jesse's got some
great stories which i can't remember any
of them for some reason
at this moment but yeah she she didn't
she could not be embarrassed
but you knew that it was based on
something that happened to her
and so there was this forgiveness that
everybody this grace that everybody
extended to her
but it's a bit much right so you you
kind of
yeah if you weren't ready for it you had
to like bolster yourself to be in her
presence probably
yeah um but it was really just a
reflection on
any any insecurity you may have
because some people are like man i wish
i could be like that i wish we could all
just
be blunt and truthful about everything
but actually i don't know i don't know
would we really like that
and are we even capable we're not
capable of it
we're not capable of just getting rid of
whatever it was
that generated the tendency to be
embarrassed
about things and it's probably i have to
assume
that if it's part of the code it was
and continues to be useful to some
degree i mean the ability to be
embarrassed about things
i think is a pretty good social
regulator
i guess as if the anticipation
of it like once you've experienced
embarrassment you want to avoid that
it's like okay you don't want to you
want to
you don't want to show any weakness or
any stupidity it's like
damn she can't even walk across the
string of christmas lights without
bringing down the whole party
you know it's like you become a lot you
don't want to be show yourself as a
liability
in any in any way so um well we talked
about
we've talked about this before too i
don't know how we we're coming back to
this
but uh the fact that a gorilla
like a silverback gorilla in order to
express dominance over another silver
silverback
will get an erection in the middle of
like yeah
try trying to fight you keep wanting to
talk about it no
but i think this is because what he's
saying
is i'm not elaine i'm not scared of you
i'm not embarrassed at all look what i
am incapable of
i'm doing right now look what's
happening right now look at what i'm
capable of
right now right yeah i mean gorilla's
figured it out
i don't think i don't think that's
necessarily the path i don't think
that's the objective i don't think
that's people walk around with you
no hanging out but this pestle is
everywhere i'm [ __ ]
i'm just saying that the ability in
certain circumstances the ability to
overcome your embarrassment maybe maybe
there is something to it but i mean
you could play possum or you could stand
back up and you could say you could just
on it say you know what
i tripped has anyone else here ever
tripped
i bet you've all tripped before this
could it could have been anybody
it'd be a nice speech to have prepared
for people it could have been it could
have been you not me
so shut your shut your
keiko yeah that might be stop laughing
at me maybe more embarrassing
if you i mean that got a little
aggressive but i do think there is a
good speech that you could have in your
back pocket for
when you embarrass yourself physically
in mixed company
people in glass houses shouldn't throw
stones or whatever
you're saying that is
okay you bunch of hypocrites that
whenever i feel embarrassed i should
i just want to yell that at the world a
bunch of hypocrites
try that on craig crayfish
on twitter my dad and my brother got
into a
fight over lima beans well okay were
were they drinking
my brother fist fighting my sister and i
ended up leaving and going to the mall
i'm so intrigued by this because first
of all let me just say
i understand i mean lima beans are worth
fighting over
is it that they both wanted the lima
beans
there was some lima beans left over
because it i mean i
as a bean lover and they didn't it
doesn't say get into a fist fight
about lima beans it was over lima beans
so it was like the they were it was
under them the lima beans were there
present and maybe taking literally
getting it too too literal
um man i mean is this the is it of a
leftover situation
or is it like that you know you didn't
make enough lima beans going back for
seconds
to me this seems like the kind of
situation where the brother
because a lot of times kids they don't
they don't really understand things like
you gotta you can't just go back and get
seconds or thirds
you're literally getting it down you're
you're making the fight about that
it could be about something you think
it's about the recipe of lima beans well
i i
i'm not going to weigh in on the
fistfight part of this but you know
in any family misunders
altercations are usually not about the
thing that it seems like they're about
yeah it's not really about lima beans
right
this is about the the
the sun not meeting the father's
expectations and the sun
feeling feeling judged and
you know i don't know yeah
i mean i'm just taking her at her word
it was it's about lima beans and i just
said i i get
i get how the passion you know can be
inflamed by the lima bean it's i know
you don't particularly like lima beans
i don't but as someone who does let me
just i feel like i can speak as an
authority here that
they are a special kind of bean they're
they don't
they're almost like a different category
of bean because if you just think about
if you say beans a lot of times people
just think of like baked beans you know
think of pinto beans something like that
you kind of need to specify lima beans
when you're talking about that
usually much larger flat lime flavored
bean
green you know brownish
and if you do it right there with some
ham hock there maybe some fat back
yeah i mean that's you talking about a
butter bean now
uh you that's how you do lima beans as
well oh lima bean is basically just a
big butter bean
yitzy raven shared
when my sister was much younger she by
mistake lit her hair on fire
by the hanukkah menorah we tell this
story year to year to year
fast forward to last year and her
daughter my niece
did the exact same thing caught her hair
on fire my brother just said
just like your mommy hashtag like mother
like daughter
man you talk about it you talk about an
exciting christmas
somebody getting their hair caught on
fire that'll do it i mean how many first
i guess this is uh
not christmas this is hanukkah how many
menorahs
today are still like literal
fire right the fun ones but i think a
lot of this has been replaced with
oh there's one there's an electric one
flame bulbs
the bulbs that look like flames that
don't move
i never fall for that by the way i've
never once fallen for
a bulb shaped like a flame and i thought
that wow that's
that's that's actually burning the
candle i've never fallen for that
i'm proud of that have you ever is there
some in restaurants
that are um that i think you would fall
for oh they're flicker
yeah they dance a little bit they've got
they've got a thing in there that's
spinning at an
irregular rate that actually makes it
look like
it's a flame now when you get on top of
it you see oh that's not what's
happening here but if
okay well when i'm on top of it i
wouldn't fall for it right but if you
just see it like if you see it from a
profile you see it from a distance okay
maybe i'm falling for it i'm not gonna
say i've never fallen for it
boy i mean how many flames on a menorah
eight well it seems like there would be
a it seems like they would be in
i think i'm i'm not and i'm i don't know
i'm gonna think there's 12.
like one in the middle yeah there's one
in the middle we're starting to whisper
because we really don't know
all i know is there's there's a lot of
there's a lot of potential for flames
here i think it's 13.
no there's not that many oh gosh we got
i mean we got to look this up
how many you know as a as a former
baptist
the the closest that that we get to
starting a fire during the holidays
and we were right nine yeah yeah nine is
not a number that we had said
um is the advent candles
and and and what we would do did they do
this in your church
so you had the advent candles that
during the advent season they
you know you start lighting different
candles on and you bring up
you you bring up a different family with
their kids yeah yeah
kids are often depending on what age
they are the kids are
sometimes given script well not only a
script
but they're sometimes they get to light
the candles some families they let the
families decide
sometimes it's like the dad goes in
there and it's like listen i'm the dad
i'm gonna light the candle
yeah and then sometimes it it's like
we're going to we're going to let
nothing shows nervous more than having
to light a candle with like that
you got to you're out of the whole
church you got to push on the thing then
you got to pull the trigger
and you might get a weak one sometimes
especially if you're in one of the later
weeks like when they've really used that
lighter a few times
because you're using you're using two
forms of pressure on one hand and you're
in front of people and you're holding
your kid a lot of [ __ ] you've got
holding your kid you're shaking too
probably and you don't you're not used
to getting up in front of the church
right and so it doesn't matter that
these people everybody's pulling for you
no one i mean people judge judge you
when you get up there that's what people
do but
everybody's pulling for you and maybe
it's a relatively small church maybe
there's 120 people
but you still have this flash speak of
embarrassment
you can't get the advent candle lit
you're immediately embarrassed and then
there's the
like then you're like am i gonna say
something am i gonna make a joke is
somebody gonna come up
to help me light this thing should i
fall flat on my face
and act like i've passed out this is a
scenario in which my dad was really good
as a person
in the actual congregation of saying
something to make everybody laugh
he'd yell from the pew yo yeah he he
he he'll stupid stan you can't light a
candle
no he'll say something like i told him
to get a new lighter you know he'll say
something that takes the pressure off of
the person not you
and that makes everybody laugh and then
the guy will like be like yeah yeah yeah
that's right then they'll go back to
keep doing it jesus turned water into
wine let's see if he can light up that
candle that's usually not
it's not a good good plan to invoke
that but that's that's the closest we
can get to
uh you know starting a fire and i'm sure
there's been some
serious advent fires well if you leave
them if you leave them burning all week
which that i hate to burst your bubble
but like
trigger warning put the kids away if
they're listening
send them away they don't leave the
advent candles burning all week
you have to re-light them i bet you they
do it like the catholic church
the further you go further you the
further you go
if you're a later family you have to
re-light all those other candles
oh yeah so there's lots of stuff to like
what a nightmare
ladybug berry tweeted
my nana bought my husband and i sexy
matching lingerie
first of all i have several questions
about this the first the least of them
is
your grandmother did this how do you
what does the man
wear to match with a woman's lingerie
um have you ever worn anything like this
i've never had matching lingerie with my
wife no
no i've never i've never actually seen
that i mean
i mean i i just i'm sure this is sexist
but
uh i've never i've never really thought
about
in in a lingerie situation what i was
right i never thought what should what
what should i have on right now i've had
i've had some um i've had some underwear
that i would never wear
otherwise i tried that a few times
what like what edible no like uh
like um special sexy briefs
really yeah i've had sex i got i got i
think i still have a pair buried in my
in my drawer somewhere it's like if you
go on a thong
uh no it's not it
the cheeks weren't out but it was
it was just more of uh not boxing
it was just it was it was just a
different kind of voice
right like they had like a red or
something they were made out of a
different material
like us like a smoother material well i
think we might be getting closer to what
nana was thinking when she bought
she maybe it was like well i got i got
you they were kind of satin
i got you a little black teddy and i got
him a black thong
you know i'm saying so maybe it didn't
come in a set thong
maybe it was just that's what she was
getting at
okay well i didn't know about that how
how would you how would you
i'm not saying i didn't know about you
doing that oh
i did i yeah i didn't i didn't know
about it i didn't really i haven't
thought about that aspect of it
for me but now i am you know just
something a little fun
okay something a little fun it's a like
a form-fitting type thing
no it's not for everyday use you know
it's just a little
it's just a little novelty i mean it's
like
all the sexy lingerie i guess there's
people who like
wear that stuff every day like the real
sexy stuff
like the lacy stuff but i don't i mean
unless you're like a dominatrix i don't
think that
something you wear all the time okay
okay that's your job
i i think that these are just like
matching boxers and like uh
like a teddy i don't think this is like
super lacy
thong situation but okay now but now
let's
go that far let's get to the fact that
your grandmother did it
she knows how this guy she knows how
right i know what y'all are doing
you know it's not a surprise to me right
so i fully endorse this
i think this is i think more grandma
should give sexy lingerie and now that i
know that there's
matching lingerie that i think more of
them should give that talk about the
first time
that christy came over to visit
like my nana and like all the neils
were together for dinner uh after dinner
nana was like we should all get a
picture you know everything was going so
great
with christy they were getting to know
her for the first time they loved her
accent
she's one of us they said nana was like
well let's get a picture
and then we all got together and then as
they were ready to take the picture she
said all right on three
everybody say six
[Laughter]
you know so at a certain age you're like
listen let's just get over this
i mean we didn't drink at the table but
we would say sex when you're taking a
picture boy
this is this happened more than once
like that was her go-to
actually no that was the only time i'd
ever heard her say that
how did people know yeah everybody
laughed and the picture was taken and it
was perfect
yeah i could see nana i mean that's her
name as well i could see nana
doing this almost as a joke but also
doing it seriously
oh yeah live it up so she
enjoy each other she hasn't said
anything about she hasn't done the sex
picture thing
since it was just a one time thing yeah
it was still it was never before
never after she pulled it out at the
perfect time
kind of like that guy beside your tesla
okay last one from zack stroud
when i was a kid i wanted people to know
i appreciated it
when they gifted me clothes for
christmas so to give the appearance of
i really care about this gift and don't
want to toss it aside like most gifted
clothes
i would sniff them not sure why
went on for a few years well zach i
definitely understand
the hyper awareness of when you open the
gift everybody's that's the moment of
the gifter
to feel to feel
joy you know to to be brimming with
satisfaction of
yes the thing that i got weeks ago and
wrapped lovingly
i'm seeing them open it right before my
eyes and look
they're happy about it even though
they're a child and it's a shirt
he still seems happy about it in fact
he's sniffing it
yeah nothing nothing feels
like a better endorsement than sniffing
something i i understand that
the principle i would probably have
stopped short from actually sniffing i
would have i probably would have hugged
it
and like maybe felt it against my face
and then i could see how that might
actually
you get your wires crossed and all of a
sudden you're sniffing a polo shirt
well and i think it's all about what you
do after you sniff it because i i
imagine zach
is like sniffing it like and then kind
of looking at the gifter and just like
just kind of nodding and smiling like it
does really convey cherish
you know my heart if you pull something
to your nose that's an intimate place
you know
the front of your face yeah because if
you serve somebody food and they
smell it and savor it
it's really zach i actually think you're
on to something i think that there
we could apply this to more things in
life
anything to where you know that someone
is watching you
to be get a sense of validation it's
like just
incorporate a long
like uh thoughtful sniff i think this
could be done in like
legal documents like the exchange of a
document
yeah so like if you you know you go
through that
process of when you buy a home you have
to sign
like 40 different things you know what
if you would
not only sign them but sniff them this
is this is this is making me think of
our
smell it but come up big what does that
like come up big signature
it's like you you you do your autograph
see you're talking about oh wow so now
i'm those yeah
but we said that if you sign your
autograph
and you can come up big you smell it and
come up big but do you smell it
i think so i think there was a smell and
then come up big
i don't remember this is a moment if you
don't remember it happened on good
mythical more
it was one of those silly mores where
things just got off the rails but we
were talking about
what's the weirdest thing you've ever
signed on someone's body and we talked
about how nascar
drivers would would sign boobies
and then somehow we were talking about
like
sign it and come up big there was no
sniffing i don't think there was
sniffing involved uh but
now there should be sniffing involved
not if it's boobies no yeah yeah i'm
talking about just for documents
well again that's a signature not an
autograph i just think
when you every gift should be should be
breathed in deeply
i think it's a great way to convey
acceptance cherish
cherishment appreciation yeah that's the
word i'm looking for
so nothing to be ashamed of here zach
you should just do it again you need to
go back to doing it again yeah
sniffing clothes i mean whenever i
i i have this sense of everybody's
watching me open these
gifts and i don't want anybody's
feelings to be hurt so what i would do
when
i got a close and i would be thinking i
need to compensate for not being
uh excited about this as a kid i would
immediately put the clothes on
like if it was a shirt i would put the
shirt on over my existing shirt
i was like nothing says that i'm willing
to wear this shirt you got me more than
actually wearing the shirt you got me
right now wow you did that i would do
that if it was a shirt or a sweater or a
pullover if it were pants
when when all the gifts were given i
might sneak away try on the pants and
come back and say
hey i tried on the i tried on the pants
you got me because there's a question
does it fit
is he gonna you know so then it's like
oh look i'm already in the pants you got
me isn't this great
what if and then they would feel relief
little black thongs from your nana
i'd wait on that again they weren't
thongs the cheeks weren't out
okay little tight-fitting briefs this is
called a banana hammock a banana hammock
yeah that well
a budded banana hammock okay would you
try that one in front of your nana
no i would not i have not i shall not
i don't want to she doesn't want me to
no one wants me to except you do you
think and i'm not going to i don't want
you to
do do you think that people are going to
try to find a way to do like zoom
gifting
i don't even thought about this mail the
gift and then
didn't wait on zoom i think for this
holiday i think i think we
we haven't thought about that we should
do that well i think sniffing
is a really really good thing in that
context because there's only so many
things you can say or do
yeah but you can definitely bring
whatever gifted it is up into your frame
and sniff it okay
well i feel i i actually feel more ready
looking back on this conversation for my
next moment of being embarrassed
i feel like i've bolstered my loins a
little bit and i'm just ready
i'm ready to not be as embarrassed when
something embarrassing happens to me
during the holidays
i'm gonna own it or i'm gonna win i'm
gonna yeah win i'm gonna put it back on
people
i got a recommendation if you're open
for i'm open for it into it
um wreck baby wreck baby one two three
four um me and christy and lando
watch something um and we were all into
it
if you got if you got a kid on the
younger side
tennis like land i don't know if the
older i think the older kids would have
been into this but they didn't
they didn't watch it um it's an
it's an apple tv series docu series
called becoming you
um we just needed something to watch
we get all the stuff that we watch as a
family if one of the family members in
there you can't watch it
you got to have a little it's just a
little filler thing uh just take it
take it to fill in a gap in your life
but it's these um
it's kids from around the globe and
they've documented their first 2000 days
on earth
told through the eyes of 100 children
across the world from nepal to japan to
borneo
each episode offers a thought-provoking
look at how children learn to think
speak and move from birth to age five
it underscores how different our
journeys can be but ultimately tells the
story of our shared humanity and
community when it comes to raising
children
you got these cute kids that you're not
responsible for and it is fascinating
how they
how they present it um they talked about
there was this one kid who was
i swear he was only three years old this
kid in uh
tokyo and i know you don't say that i
don't do that on your biscuits you don't
do that on your biscuits you only do it
on the show
but there's this there's this thing
called
uh my first errand
and it's like a rite of passage for kids
as young as three years old could be
like six or seven years old
and the kid goes out on his own erin and
they documented it on this on the first
episode and they say all right you need
to go pick up
so and so from the grocery store i love
this and then they
this kid is three years old and he's
like
dude he's he's walking around tokyo like
using public transportation
going to the bodega oh my goodness and
like they
and they the cameras weren't too hidden
because they like filmed the interaction
with the bodega and he's like do you
have money
and it's but so the parents are the
parents like
this is a japanese tradition the parents
are not there the parents do not follow
them
this would be controversial in america
and they come back
the kids comes back with an
understanding of
a new level of capability at three
as young as three that's how old this
kid was and
yeah and it's a it's a rite of passage
in japanese culture
called my first aaron and in fact
there's a television show
in japan where they have hidden cameras
and they document
kids doing this their first errand so
it's like something that like everybody
knows about
you'll see like a three-year-old kid
just walking walking
along the crossing so you don't say and
they know you need to know
are you looking for your mom you're like
no i'm getting a pack of cigarettes for
my granddad
they all assume that that's what's
happening yeah in this television show
i would love to watch it hajamite no
atsukai or my first aaron has been
running for more than 25 years oh my
goodness
this is a thing isn't that so cool so
that was just a little part of episode
one but
and they skip between all these kids
that like show the development process
and it's uh it's very heartwarming
and you learn some stuff i didn't know
about my first airing it's too late for
our kids now
25 years that show's been running over
there i mean in america you get
you get arrested for letting your kids
go to the playground
without your being there i mean there
was like there was a well and
it i've never been to tokyo but
i mean in this one article i was reading
they were it's culturally difficult
it's different like those parents would
say i would never
set my kid loose in new york city or
somewhere else
yeah to do their first errand yeah if
it's a culturally accepted thing
super low crime that kind of thing then
it's it's a it's a different thing
uh but wow so i i've only watched
episode one and watched it last night
but uh you know i recommend it it's uh
it's pretty cool okay i'll think about
watching it now that you recommended it
yeah just just that's all i ask think
about it and you know what
next time you're in an embarrassing
situation just
do what that guy did next to your tesla
and just shake it off
i've been sitting on that one um okay so
we we is it we it's next week the last
episode of this season yeah
am i right about that okay yes we're
doing our top ten
fair warning yeah we're doing each doing
our top 10 of 2020 like we've been doing
the past couple of years and that'll be
the last episode of uh
of 2020 and we'll come back not too far
into the new year
with the next season i got to start
working on my list
hashtag gear biscuits to watch more ear
biscuits click on the playlist on the
right to watch the previous episode of
your biscuits click on the playlist to
the left and don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best